thank you
foreign
okay
the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne who was at
the house adjourned from the session of
May 26 2022.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed me the eyes have it the
house is adjourned a house will attend
to a Prayer by house chaplain Reverend
Bob Stewart pastor of Saint Paul's
United Methodist Church in Manchester
good afternoon
let us be in a spirit of Prayer
a loving and gracious God
we know that life is a gift from you o
Creator God
we are grateful and thankful that we
were blessed to be in service with
representative Mary Griffin
who you have called Home in June at the
age of 96.
Mary has served you in this great state
of New Hampshire for many years
Mary served her constituents with
honesty and integrity
as she was the oldest active serving
state legislator in the country at the
time of her death
God we ask that you be with those that
mourn Mary's passing as she will be
sorely missed by many in this chamber
be with her family and friends and I
pray that you walk with them in their
grief
let us pause for a moment of silence as
we remember Mary this day
thank you Mary for the countless hours
of your service
oh compassionate God we ask that you
also be with our colleague Gary Hopper
we are praying for Gary in this time of
physical trial and ask that you surround
those closest to him with your love and
compassion
We Gather today together to tend to the
business of our state and ask that you
be with each member represented
here today
give each member the wisdom to make
sound decisions that will benefit the
people they represent
let us as the body of the New Hampshire
House of Representatives
regardless of our party affiliation
treat each other with respect and
dignity and that we work towards the
common good of all the people of our
state
o god of love be with all the leaders of
this house as they work diligently to
conduct the business before us this day
I ask that you keep your hand upon each
member and keep them faithful
fruitful and steady as they complete the
work set before them
we praise and glorify your Holy Name
most high God as we work together today
in peace and harmony with each other
amen
the chair recognizes the dean of the
house Senator Laura panelakis who will
lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance
energy
the chair recognizes Michael T brown of
New London who will now sing on national
anthem
[Music]
by the dancers
right
what so proud ly we held
at the twilights
last gleaming
who's brought stripes
and bright
stars
through the peril
foreign
all the
Ram parts we
watched
were so Gallant
ly
streaming I am the
rockets red glare
the bombs bursting
in air
gave proof through the night
that our flag was still there
oh say does that Star Spangled Banner
[Music]
or the land
of the free
and the whole home of the brain
s
[Music]
[Applause]
also attend to leave
Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Burros Ellis Hopper
kittrich Janice Schmidt the day
important business Representatives Iyer
Bartlett Amanda Bolden Buco contos Cody
Creighton gorg infantine Kaczynski
Kelsey Mayville Macbeth O'Hara
O'Hearn plett Suzanne Smith Mark Warden
Weber Weston yakubovic the day illness
in the family Representative Bob Elliott
the day death in the family
representative snow
these leaves shall be granted unless
otherwise ordered by the house house
will attend to the introduction of
guests Mr Speaker please welcome Sophia
Beyond de Lilo guest of Representative
nutting Wong Bill Palmer guest of
Representative oxenham Scott Lawrence
guest of Representative petrigno Pam
Dancy and Dan kulis wife and guest of
Representative Mills Gabrielle Watson
guest of Representative canark
Bobby bodeman guest of Representative
Marsh Susan amen wife of Representative
amen Heather Pearl wife of
Representative Pearl
Susan elberger William Darby Linda Ryan
Carrie speier Danny Mills Shelley Devine
and Alicia Gregg guest of
Representatives Cohen Vale and tolerski
Sherry gold and Stephanie payer guests
of Representative Pimentel and Kaplan
Christine
ordinance guest of Representative Craig
Jesse Baldwin and Dave and Jennifer
zamanski guests of the house clerk they
are with us in the gallery today
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
foreign
everybody to turn your voting machines
on
the house will now attend to a memorial
resolution
Mr Speaker
house resolution 24
memorializing Mary E Griffin of Windham
whereas we have learned with profound
sorrow of the passing of our colleague
and friend Mary E Griffin who is serving
her 13th term as a state represented
representing the town of Wyndham
and when whereas a dedicated public
servant
Mary Griffin served three terms on the
committee on Municipal and County
government in 10 terms on the committee
on Ways and Means served 10 terms as
Vice chair of the Rockingham County
delegation and served on dozens of
committees and commissions and whereas
Mary Griffin was known for her grace
style and Poise dancing her way into
winning the MS senior New Hampshire
competition in 1993
and leading this body in the national
anthem on a myriad of occasions
and whereas Mary Griffin was extremely
active in her community chairing
numerous boards serving countless causes
and taping her weekly television show
which featured more political guests
than some well-known New Hampshire
networks a dedication that continued
right up until her illness left her in
care
and whereas above all Mary Griffin was
the personification of a gentle lady
who worked well with all her legislative
colleagues speaking ill of none and
reciprocally receiving none either
now be it therefore resolved by the
House of Representatives and regular
session convened Mary E Griffin be
granted our highest praise and accolades
and offered our profound thanks for her
service to her home community and the
state of New Hampshire offered by the
House of Representatives
please rise and join me in a moment of
silence and honor and memory of
representative from Windham honorable
Mary Griffin
thank you
also attended Communications
Mr Speaker communication date of May 27
2022 via email Dear Mr Speaker with the
conclusion of our final session day
before the summer break I wish to take
this time to inform you that I am
resigning from the New Hampshire house
effective immediately it has been an
honor and privilege to represent the
citizens of Hudson and Pelham these past
four years running and serving as a
State Rep is one of the best decisions
I've ever made I'll treasure the
opportunity to serve and the many dear
friendships with legislators staff and
lobbyists I've gained along the way
my wife Kathy and I decided about 15
years ago to someday retire in Florida
full-time we are relocating to the
villages to our home we recently
purchased and will no longer be residing
in New Hampshire Kathy has waited
patiently these past two years to allow
me to serve a second term I hope to
remain politically active in Florida via
various organizations assisting with
campaigns or perhaps running for office
once again locally the decision to
resign and move out of state is surely
Bittersweet for as much as I look
forward to the next chapter in my life
I'll look back fondly on these last four
years serving in Concord and living in
the great state of New Hampshire the
past 17. thank you for your support and
understanding sincerely Bob Greene
via email on June 7 2022 dear clerk
Smith it is with great sadness and
regret that I'm sending you this letter
of resignation effective June 1st I am
also advising the house Democratic
office and our leader Cody it has been a
tremendous honor and privilege and
humbling experience to serve nearly six
years in this historic and venerable
body representing Nashua and the granite
state as a whole I've met and worked
with so many wonderful people true
public servants working in Concord
surrounded by history and tradition has
been an experience I will never forget
as you are aware I've had serious health
issues and now find that the disease is
progressing much faster than expected
making it nearly impossible for me to
participate in any meaningful way in the
house activities
secondly even if my health had a loud
attendance I will be moving to Keen with
my daughter in the first week of June
thereby moving out of the city of Nashua
and Hillsborough County I'm sure excuse
me I am sorry to leave so much work
unfinished especially when we have so
many opportunity to improve lives and
benefit our people
and I recognize what excellent work the
house has done so far and I feel that I
have let left
spelling her and I've left the house
down lately and not carrying my weight
due to illness I'm impressed by all the
great contributions made by by our
hard-working colleagues I'm so so sorry
I can no longer be a part of it I have
enjoyed the camaraderie best wishes for
the remainder of the session sincerely
skip cleaver
via email on July 18 2022. Mr Speaker
according to the law of the land the New
Hampshire state constitution part second
article 14th as of Monday July 18th at
12 pm I will cease to be qualified to
represent the inhabitants of District 8
of bel-neck County it has been an honor
to serve the people of my district in
the state of New Hampshire as a state
representative sincerely Raymond J
Howard
via email on August 8 2022 Mr clerk it
is with great sadness that I inform you
on the entire house of my departure from
my role as representative for
Hillsborough District 22. as I am
leaving the district to pursue my
education I have enjoyed my time in the
house making many friends along the way
I wish the best for every member of the
house and for the institution itself my
resignation shall be effective
immediately goodbye and good luck Tony
the branch
August 11 2022 via email Mr clerk please
accept this res this message is my
resignation from the house effective
immediately Andrew Bolden
via letter to the speaker August 30th
2022. Mr Speaker in the recent past we
had a conversation about life changes
and decisions in my household as my
partner continues through the process of
selling his business here we've
purchased a home and we'll be relocating
to Tennessee while a decision was
difficult we feel it is best for us at
this time over the next several weeks I
will be away handling the move and
working on that property to secure our
full arrival for this reason I think it
only fair that because I cannot be
present to perform my duties it would be
proper for me to turn in my resignation
my time in the legislature in our
Republican caucus with our very talented
leaders has been one of the most
rewarding times of my life I've had the
opportunity to serve with and learn from
the best and hopefully my contributions
were thought of as positive for our
great state I thank you for your trust
in the rest of leadership in particular
our Majority Leader Jason Osborne I
thank it for his wisdom and guidance and
to my fellow legislators I appreciated
learning from each and every one of you
keep up the good work I wish the best
for all of you and continue to hope for
the continuance of legislating from the
liberty and freedom perspective because
it is
in this where each individual citizen
will gain the most we are here to work
for the people and should always think
of how each piece of legislation that is
presented for debate and discussion will
affect them in Liberty Herschel Nunes
via email September 1st 2022 Dear Mr
Speaker and esteemed colleagues I hereby
resign from the house effective
September 11 2012 due to the fact that I
am moving out of state it has been a
pleasure and an honor to serve the town
of Exeter in the New Hampshire house my
parting wish for the chamber is that
those who labor within its May and
future find new ways to remember what we
all have in common and special spend
less time concentrating on what divides
Us best regards Lisa bunker
house will attend to a motion to suspend
the house rules
Mr Speaker representative Osborne and
walner move that all necessary house
rules be so far suspended as to allow
introduction and consideration at the
present time of House Bill 2023 FNA
making Appropriations to the Department
of energy for a state emergency fuel
assistance program and a supplemental
electric benefit and relative to the
electric low-income program fund without
the required referral to committee
public hearing and report from committee
and if pass allow for immediate third
reading a copy of which is in your seat
pockets
chair recognizes representative Prout
to speak against the motion
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker I oppose the motion to
suspend the rules
the process of having hearings on bills
is important listening to public
feedback on proposed language allowing
time for many eyes to read bills and
point out flaws in the language is
important
one such flaw that is obvious in this
bill is that it has no phasing out
provision if a household makes one
dollar too much you get nothing
this perverse incentive for some to make
a little less money turn down those
extra hours to stay under the limit is
enough to make me vote against this bill
but also by bringing this bill to us via
suspension of the rules we have no
opportunity to draft floor amendments
they would have had to have been turned
into the clerk by 4 pm yesterday on a
bill that isn't formally introduced
unless we pass the motion before us
even if I wanted to propose a compromise
to make this terrible wealth
redistribution program that will take
funds that came from all the taxpayers
of New Hampshire and give it to
approximately three percent of
households slightly less abhorrent
There's no practical way for me to do so
this is a bad way of doing business
this is why our rules normally do not
allow for us to do this
and why we should all vote against
suspending them today
I ask you to press the red button and
join me in saying no to this motion to
suspend the rules
thank you Mr Speaker
I recognize representative Abramson
to speak against the motion
thank you
Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker I rise in opposition to the
motion to suspend the rules on this
measure
for the simple reason that I contacted
my constituents in Seabrook and Hampton
and Hampton Falls and asked their
opinion on this and they thought that
this was a terrible idea that it was
described as a drop in the bucket or
would have no impact whatsoever but I
think that it would have a small impact
the perhaps five or six percent of of
people in the state who would actually
qualify and actually receive some
benefit from the money there's no
question that they would receive a small
amount of savings but the other 94 95
percent of people hate it when they see
their tax money taken from them and
given to benefit someone else and that's
always been the case and no one could
possibly serve in this house and not
know about the the the issue that
taxpayers hate paying more in taxes and
then seeing someone else get the money
and then being disqualified from getting
the benefit on themselves but there's a
bigger economic issue I have a
background in economics and one of the
first things I learned in my high school
economics class was that any time you
subsidize something any taxpayers
subsidies merely drive up the cost this
will not increase the amount of energy
or the amount of goods and services that
we're able to consume it will only
increase the subsidies to the energy
sector this has been viewed by some and
described by some in our state as
corporate welfare although it's in an
indirect form the ultimate benefit I
think will not go to the general public
that the general public will see the
loss in an opportunity this that
representative this is about the
suspension of the rules not the bill
itself
all right
um I apologize for that
um but the bill is not the bill has not
been through a public hearing and all of
these concerns that the public has
raised they have not had the opportunity
yet
to express these at a public hearing or
through the emails and phone calls that
we receive as members of this house and
yet they've been when we do have the
chance to go to our constituents they
haven't had the chance to read this bill
but they've heard about some of the
details and they hate it it's just
another it is just another taxpayer
subsidy low taxes are the result of low
spending and low spending can only
happen if we show the regular discipline
to vote no on these big spending items
thank you
Jay I recognize Representative Steven
Smith to speak
for the motion
thank you Mr Speaker let's dial this
back to what you're actually about to
vote on you are about to vote on whether
or not we will consider the bill not the
bill whether we can talk about it
whether it exists even that's what we're
voting on today why are we doing it this
way because some would say that the
situation is an emergency it's about to
affect Granite Staters now next month
certainly and cannot wait for us to get
around to it next January through March
or whenever the bill would actually be
considered Granite Staters need us to
discuss this today because winter is
coming please support the motion
the motion before us is suspension of
the rules
a division has been called this will be
a division vote members take your seats
make sure you turn on your voting
machines
turn on your voting machines
representative Bell disarro was asked
for a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded this
will be a division vote
chair recognizes representative Burke
for parliamentary inquiry
foreign
thank you
Mr Speaker
if I know we are not Robin Hood
if I know the little amount to be passed
out will not make the person receiving
it because it won't be enough
the person not receiving it
a representative yes this is about the
suspension of the rules not the bill
itself
thank you Mr Speaker I was thinking the
same thing myself
so I will
change my speech then
Aaron
lastly Mr Speaker
foreign
if I know taxation is theft would I now
press the red button thank you Mr
Speaker
I also be in order
chair recognizes representative Smith
for parliamentary inquiry
Stephen Smith thank you Mr Speaker
if I think that it is the wrong message
to tell our constituents we didn't even
want to talk about this today while they
see the effect things are having on them
then would I press the green button so
we can at least tell them we talked
about it
the question is on suspension of the
rules this is a division vote in favor
you'll press the green button of your
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
see if I remember how to do this
foreign
[Music]
president an opportunity to vote
also attend the state of the vote
259 voting a
166 voting a the motion passes by the
two-thirds
recognize the clerk for a motion Mr
Speaker Representatives Osborne and
walner offer the following resolved that
the suspension of the rules adopted by
two-thirds of the house in accordance
with the listen the possession of the
clerk House Bill 2023 F A making
Appropriations to the Department of
energy for a state emergency fuel
assistance program and a supplemental
electric benefit and relative to the
electric low-income program funds shall
be by this resolution read a first and
second time
this is the introduction motion are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye welcome pose
nay the eyes have it the motion is
adopted
representative Smith moves the bill
ought to pass
chair recognizes representative Stephen
Smith
thank you Mr Speaker
so you may have seen advertisements
about a energy relief plan that does not
exist the governor's 100 million dollar
relief program that is not before you
today
that would have sent a very small amount
of money to almost everybody
personally not speaking for everyone
else that seems like a meaningless
political gesture to me instead I wanted
to do something that was actually
effective as did many others so if you
base this on the numbers right now the
LIHEAP program helps people with energy
and electric and fuel assistance that's
the low income heat energy assistance
program and it helps people up to 60
percent of the median income in New
Hampshire
but we have inflation we have Rising
costs so it seems reasonable that if you
are say 15 above that bracket that they
have right now you may be feeling like
the people in that bracket felt a couple
years ago
so it seems right to try to do at least
a slight correction and give those
people some assistance so what this bill
does is gives them two hundred dollars
for their electric bill
450 for their fuel oil which is a decent
amount of fuel oil
it's not going to fix the problem but
it's their money it's sitting in the
bank we might as well give it back to
them it does them more good than it does
us
there were arguments about well when you
do these handouts people will just spend
it that's actually not a possibility
with this bill the payments will go
directly to the utility companies to the
electric company to the oil company so
nobody's getting a check that's not how
it works
it's a small amount of relief but it's
what we can do and like I said the
money's in the bank I'm never against
giving the people their money back I
hope you can support this measure today
I forgot to mention on the last motion
representative Foster that cleared a
conflict of interest and did not
participate
uh chair recognizes representative McGee
esteemed colleagues
I rise today in support of the bill
appropriating State emergency fuel
assistance a supplemental electric
benefit for moderate income earners and
additional funding for existing
low-income electric assistance program
the Eep
uh in the governor's original press
conference
responding to the public utility
commission's approval of an electric
price hike from 11 cents a kilowatt to
22 cents a kilowatt he announced a plan
to Credit One hundred dollars to every
electric bill
payer in New Hampshire regardless of
need but the impact for Bill payers
according to eversource would be an
average of about seventy dollars per
month for six months so although the
chicken in every pot solution was an
easy one it was not adequate
then the speaker and others raised the
concerns about giving help to those who
really didn't need it and they suggested
that we also look at developing a state
funded heating assistance program so in
addition to the federally funded
low-income fuel assistance program
Target those median income earners
for whom utility rate increases could
mean the difference between Heating and
eating
this effort the temporary State
emergency fuel assistance program was
designed to help the people above the
low-income assistance threshold of 60
percent of median income as my colleague
representative Smith just mentioned so
where we landed with the bill is that
people who earn between 60 and 75
percent of median income can now apply
for up to two hundred dollars or for 200
in electric assistance if they qualify
they get the whole amount there's no
variable
and up to 450 in fuel assistance which
also includes people who have electric
heat so it's not just oil and gas it's
if you're heating with electric you
would also be eligible
so that ends up being 650 dollars total
in emergency utility bill assistance for
those middle income earners for both
programs
now we have a concern that the number of
low-income electric assistants
households is bigger than the funding
provided in this bill but there is an
additional seven million dollars that
was added to bolster that fund which you
know we are hoping is going to go a long
way to helping those people in the low
income category to meet their their
bills this this winter
so although very little help was sought
from my caucus and we would have helped
we would have welcomed the chance for
further collaboration on this we are
happy to say that we helped secure the
increase in the state emergency electric
assistance payout uh from 100 up to two
hundred dollars per household
because that was the original problem
that we were trying to resolve was the
the increase in electric bills
so we certainly would have preferred for
that to be closer to the 420 the average
person will pay in higher electric bills
over the six months this rate increase
will be in effect
um and we can work to implement energy
policies that would promote greater
Independence and Market competitions so
that we have better Hedges against this
kind of a price spike in the future but
while there's more that we could do
there's always more that we can do
um and so that is why I'm asking for
your support in passing this much needed
relief for granite Staters thanks
Independence which I recognize what I
was in a Marjorie Smith
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker
I imagine many of you in this room
has just felt the Earth shake
and the reason that the Earth has shaken
is because
my esteemed colleague from Charlestown
and I who share a last name do not
always
share positions but today we do
and we do
recognizing for each of us that we
believe that we would rather light a
candle
than curse the darkness
I don't think either of us is thrilled
with this spill
I cannot speak and I wouldn't dare to
speak for my colleague from Charleston
but I can speak for myself
this is a Band-Aid it is a short-term
Band-Aid it is not any more than that
but
if you have scraped your knee
a Band-Aid helps
and many many of our constituents are
struggling
with the fact that the utilities
have dramatically increased the charges
that will be felt by people at every
level every level of income
and the governor's initial proposal
thought the same relief for everybody
and that makes no sense the reason we
have government is because we believe
together
we can create a life that is better
for all of us than if we each are on our
own and that means that we have to look
at the people who need the most help
if I had my druthers I would begin by
changing the people who serve on the
Public Utilities Commission
I don't have much others
and I recognize that if I had my
druthers I would not be favoring a
short-term six-month solution but a
long-term change in how we address the
very real problems that we will be
facing in this
City in this County in this state and
this nation on how we deliver and what
we deliver to meet our energy needs but
today we have a short-term Band-Aid
before an opportunity to do a little bit
an opportunity to recognize
I'm going to use a Chinese expression I
hope no one then says I'm a Chinese
Communist sympathizer but I
some of you will get that joke
um
I a journey of a Thousand Miles begins
with one step
and this is one step
and the next step and the step after
that will be taken by the next
legislature but to not take the first
step today would be to deny a modicum of
relief to people who desperately need it
so I hope that you will join all the
Smiths in the legislature who will
support this legislation thank you
Jay I recognize representative umberger
thank you Mr Speaker
I guess I have to change my name to
Smith
so um
I will be representative Smith for the
next few moments if there's if there's
no objection
first of all
I want people to understand
that in order to receive any of this
money the people will have to apply for
it
so just because you earn within that 60
to 75 percent
of the median income doesn't mean I'm
going to send you
money to your fuel oil company you must
apply for it and so if you don't want to
apply for it fine
if you do want to apply for it great
so that's that's number one
number two I have heard Rumblings about
how we are totally depleting our Surplus
we're not
the final figures for FY 22 will be
available
uh right after 30 September
right now we still have with all this
money taken out
we still have a surplus of a minimum of
120 million dollars
so those of you that want that money to
go to the rainy day fund will make that
decision after September
but there is still Surplus money
and in case you're not following what's
going on in 23
July and August also had significant
surpluses
so we are not depleting under any
circumstances the dollars that we have
available to do good things in New
Hampshire
so I ask you to please support this
because you are helping your friends and
your neighbors
you are not helping me
because my family income is greater than
a hundred thousand just in case you
wanted to know
if you didn't want to know that's okay
too but so it's no no Financial benefit
to me so I can vote my conscience
but I do ask that you support this for
everyone in your community and in your
state in this state because I think it's
important we do not want anyone outside
or inside freezing to death
with 50 blankets on them hoping that
that's going to keep them warm this
winter thank you
the motion before us
is HB 2023 the motion is ought to pass
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes the eyes have
it and the motion is adopted
yeah I know I have a pi for you okay I'm
sorry can I be recognized yeah
based on the the rules of the house and
the rules of the other chamber if the
other chamber decides to do any
Shenanigans and stick amendments on this
are we going to require a second
suspension of the rules to consider
their amended version
they've already not today they've
already been informed that we're not
going to accept it thank you
jarek
J recognizes representative Osborne for
third reading motion
Mr Speaker representative Osborne moves
that HB 2023 making Appropriations to
the Department of energy for a state
emergency fuel assistance program and a
supplemental benefit and relatively
electric low-income program fund be by
title be read by title only and that
this the third reading motion be applied
by this resolution and that its title be
the same as adopted and then it'd be
pressed at the present time
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
his name the eyes have it the motion is
adopted
house will attend to the governor's veto
message on House Bill 52 apportioning
congressional districts
the question before the house is
notwithstanding the governor's veto said
House Bill 52 become law
chair recognizes
the chair recognized representative
Bergeron
thank you Mr Speaker
I Rise to oppose the question that house
bill 52 shall become law despite the
governor's veto of the bill
House Bill 52 pertains to apportioning
congressional district
the bill passed the house by a very
small margin in fact the motion to table
the bill uh failed by just one vote
and the bill was sent to the governor's
desk even though he said if it reached
his desk he would veto it and he did
just that
the state's primary elections are behind
us
voters in the first congressional
district have chosen their candidates
Democrats have nominated Chris Pappas
Republicans have dominated Caroline
Levitt
if we override the governor's veto
neither of those candidates will be
residents of the district that they seek
to represent
because neither of those candidates
would be residents within the proposed
boundaries of the first congressional
district under house bill 52.
the Court's Congressional map moved five
towns and about 9 000 people from One
District to the other
House Bill 52 would have moved more than
a half million people from 29 cities and
towns to another District that's more
than 36 percent of the state's
population
thus many of the voters who supported
Chris Pappas or Caroline Levitt in the
primary would not have an opportunity to
vote for them in November
that's not fair to our voters or
respectful of their wishes
with less than nine weeks to go before
the general election now is not the time
to alter the congressional districts by
overriding The veto on House Bill 52. as
such police press the red no button to
oppose the question before us thank you
chair recognize representative Abramson
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I rise
in support of HB 52 notwithstanding the
governor's veto the proposed map is not
perfect nothing made by man is
yet it's done about as well as any
committee could Benjamin Franklin said
after Thomas Jefferson's Declaration of
Independence was re being Rewritten that
he had made it a point never to drop any
important document that was later to be
subject the subject of editing by some
committee
it's been said that Franklin was not
chosen to drop the original draft of the
Declaration because he might conceal a
joke within it
but if all the plans drawn up by various
groups and committees this map is the
best or at least it is the least bad
Mr Speaker the famous salamander shape
District in Massachusetts that gave rise
to the term gerrymander
has the top of that creature's head
right on my property in Seabrook and
Salisbury
for 170 years to
bring some of you back through some of
the history of this many voters
supported Republicans and Republicans
campaigned on this for a very long time
precisely because we did not
gerrymandered districts but produce maps
that were fair or Fair
more independent and more competitive
that is they were as good as they could
be
and we pointed out the dangers in those
years of gerrymandering which uh as the
other side had said earlier Southern
Democrats had used to lock up Southern
legislatures until the 21st century
this proposed map is better because it
leaves two competitive districts and two
relatively compact districts in facing
the reality of the usual midterm
backlash which we must consider from the
party that holds the White House polling
indicates that it's unlikely that
members of the minority caucus will have
as much impact next year so I'm asking
members of the minority to give serious
consideration to this map this year
the motion before us is
the motion to override the governance so
you know on HB 52 state constitution
requires a roll call two-thirds vote is
required to override a veto if you're in
favor of having the bill become law you
will press the green button if you're
opposed you wish to sustain the
governor's veto you will press the red
button
this is going to be a roll call Members
take their seats
foreign
the motion before members take their
seats the motion before us is whether we
override the governor's veto on HB 52.
it requires a con Constitution requires
a roll call and two-thirds if you're in
favor of having this bill become law you
will press the green button if you are
opposed you wish to sustain the
governor's veto you will press the red
button
warning stations are open for 30 seconds
representative
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
also attended the state of the vote
103 voting a 220 voting a
Governor's veto is sustained
house will attend to the governor's veto
message on House Bill 275 relative to
Declaration of a state of emergency
chair recognized representative growth
thank you Mr Speaker
I always say 4 colon 45 without this
bill empowers the general court to
terminate in an emergency order or an
executive order by majority vote
this is a power that we're already
that we already have
and that this bill does not increase or
diminish the current power that we have
we're all adults we are representatives
of our constituents we call we come to
conquer when called by the speaker
and there's no further action needed on
this thank you
Jay I recognize representative Edwards
uh thank you Mr Speaker I I rise today
to talk to everyone who's taken an oath
to our Constitution
and just as a basic reminder of our
constitutional framework establishes
that the power that is is used on behalf
of the people rests with the legislature
we pass the laws and then after we pass
them the executive can agree or disagree
but the power of the people rests in the
legislature and what what we've found
ourselves in a situation is that the way
HB 275
is is resting based on this veto is that
the governor the executive branch has
too much power an unconstitutional
amount of power I think we all can agree
that there's a reasonable amount of time
that the executive must act in an
emergency and we've said for the purpose
of this bill that it's uh 90 days or
excuse me 84 days the 90 days is the War
Powers Act which limits the president's
authority to deploy military force for
90 days before the Congress must be
informed and have an opportunity to act
and and so why did Congress do that and
why should we override this veto it's
for the same reason
the power of the people rests in the
legislature when separation of powers
was created at the founding it was
thought that each body within the
government would jealously exercise its
prerogatives
and so I would ask you today not on
behalf of us but on behalf of future
legislatures to jealously guard our
legislative prerogative and
um
override this veto so that the
legislature must permit the executive
branch to continue extraordinary
emergency Powers Beyond an initial 84
days
I think 84 days should be enough to to
deal with a lot of emergencies and
certainly if it's going to last beyond
84 days the people need an opportunity
to speak and we speak on behalf of the
people so I'm going to ask for a roll
call I'm also going to ask that you vote
green when the time comes thank you very
much
also be in order
the motion before us is
notwithstanding the governor's real cell
HP 275 become law
the state constitution requires a roll
call two-thirds vote is required to
override a veto
chair recognizes the representative
Grotti
for a parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker
it is our responsibility to represent
our cons oh if I know sorry that it is
our responsibility to represent our
consistency wait a minute
this this will be a role called voter
members must take this seat still
I thought I'd done that sorry
remember I may continue thank you I'm
going to start over since I started
incorrectly uh number will suspend for a
minute
I'm a little rusty at this so forgive me
foreign
so I'm groda you now you may continue
that
as a elected official by my constituents
it is my responsibility and my
um
represents my Integrity that I represent
them wholeheartedly
and it is my responsibility to come at
the heed of the call of the speaker
when this body wishes to terminate
an executive order under RSA colon 45
and we do not need this added
legislation
would I not press the red button and
sustain the governor's veto thank you
chair recognizes
of Tony Vegas we're a parliamentary
inquiry
if I know that HB 275 would permit the
governor to declare a state of emergency
for up to 84 days without action by this
legislature
and if I know that this body met sooner
than that after the Declaration of even
the recent unprecedented emergency
and if I know that there is a tremendous
difference between this legislature
having the power to act and having the
duty to act as required by our
constitution as representatives of the
people when it might be easier to shirk
that Duty and hit leave the hard
decisions to the governor and finally if
I know that a state of emergency is a
truly extraordinary thing that it is the
suspension of this constitutionally
mandated separation of powers would I
press the green button to pass House
Bill 275 regardless of the governor's
veto thank you hmm
the motion before us is notwithstanding
the governor's veto HB 275 become law
state constitution requires a roll call
with two-thirds vote is required to
override a veto
if you're in favor of the bill becoming
law you will press the green button if
you opposed and wish to sustain the
governance veto you will press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
as long as
representative ham
ster
I'll say Mr Speaker
Walmart Mr President had an opportunity
to vote
also attend the state of the vote
157 voting yay 167.49 Governor's veto
was sustained
a house will attend
to the governor's veto message
on House Bill 319.
requiring students in the university and
Community College systems of New
Hampshire to pass the United States
citizenship and Immigration Services
Civics naturalization testing
chair recognizes representative moffatt
thank you Mr Speaker
thank you thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker the philosopher Victor cousin
stated that quote if ignorance is bliss
there should be more happy people
Mr Speaker this legislature passed two
wonderful Civics bills last year HB uh
319 HB 320. HP 320 which is now law
called for our high school grads to pass
the citizenship test had a wonderful
signing ceremony beautiful
now it's system measure or brother
measure HP
319 that we're looking at here uh asked
for the same thing to happen for college
students
um now we first want to thank the
governor for meeting directly with me
and a co-sponsor showing us the respect
to convey his concerns one of the
concerns was if
the high school students have already
passed it why why do the college
students need to pass and quickly
there's several answers to that
half the UNH students from out of state
many of the community college students
are in their 30s so there was a gap
and I'll also say I spent 12 years in
the University system I spent 20 years
in the community college system and I
can tell you that this bill is important
and is needed now when the the bill had
a hearing the both the university system
and the community college system were
neutral they did not take a position but
an accreditation agency official was
deployed and who Darkly warned uh or
shared some misinformation she said this
could cost 750 a test not true uh the
test is free it's it's part of the uh uh
the public domain
um it could be done online it could be
done as many times as necessary for a
student to uh to pass the test
then it was later stated and repeated on
the other side of the wall that we'd be
the first state in the country to have
such a measure as this uh also untrue
there's around 20 states that have
similar requirements for college
graduates to Simply pass a citizenship
test
uh
indeed after this body first past 319
last year it got a great deal of
attention
it was in the newspapers and there were
some polls one poll showed that 80
percent of the uh New Hampshire
residents supported the notion of having
college students pass this as a
graduation requirement
but the most egregious message that the
accreditation person The Hired Gun so to
speak had to do with her message this is
important
it's all important but this is
particularly important to you and to us
I'm going to paraphrase what she said
but her message was you can't tell us
what to do
now think about that
you can't tell us what to do
talk about the need for civics lesson
that the that mentality of you can't
tell us what to do should concern every
one of us
if if you agree with that that you can
go ahead and press the red button
but
the people and the peoples elected
representatives which is you and us if
we think that this is important and if
we want college graduates to to show
this uh competency then uh yeah we can
do that
it's a bipartisan bill
one staunch supporter was a great friend
of of most all of us the late Democratic
representative from Manchester
who sat in seat
5 24.
empty today of course we lost our last
December
but she spent a lifetime in education
and she understood the importance of
civics fundamentals to good citizenship
she actually offered a pi to HB 320 last
year when we passed past that one
so overturning a veto is and should be a
heavy lift that's Civics but I encourage
my colleagues to again again vote for HB
319 to send the right message to the
people
that we hear their desire
that a college degree means more than
maybe it does now
passing this would increase the value of
a college diploma it would increase
public support for college education
so the great entrepreneur Jim Rohn said
ignorance is not Bliss ignorance is
poverty ignorance is Devastation
ignorance is tragedy this bill would
strike a mighty blow a significant blow
against ignorance and they ask that you
again vote for it thank you Mr Speaker
Gea recognize representative Abramson
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I rise
in support of HB 319 and uh uh in spite
of the governor's veto
requiring that Civics be taught for
University students the governor
recognizes that we recently on a near
party line vote added the teaching of
civics to our graduation requirements
already that much is true
in fact over a hundred years ago
uh that was one of the promises made by
socialist and Progressive activists who
marched and paraded in the 19 teens and
20s to justify changing from private
tuition-funded schools to tax-funded
government schooling
though some recent high school graduates
couldn't find the Bill of Rights nor
know its contents because that promise
largely has not been kept and I'm sorry
to say that that is still true of some
of my generation
I hate to admit it but it is true
from Colonial times to almost World War
II Those Old Brick private schools were
six grade levels ahead of today's
government schools the problem with the
reasoning in sununa's veto message as it
ignores the fact that over 43 percent of
unh's students come from out of state
and many more of our continuing
education students are adults who never
went to high school in New Hampshire I
attended both the University of New
Hampshire and Great Bay Community
College and those are great schools but
I never went to high school in New
Hampshire
most of the students entering College
couldn't find the words uh common law in
our constitution
nor understand why the framers saw the
Second Amendment as being so important a
degree from a New Hampshire University
will simply guarantee less if we are
sending students out into the world who
know nothing of their fourth amendment
privacy rights Fifth Amendment property
rights and sixth amendment due process
rights we live in a society now where
many of our neighbors do not fully
understand Tuesday's State primary for
the importance of grand juries and
limiting the emissions of indictments
nor the duties given to voters to remove
those Petty tyrants and control freaks
from elective office who might violate
our basic rights
Mr Speaker the New Hampshire GOP
platform States we believe that
individual liberty is guaranteed under
the Constitution of the United States
and New Hampshire that the liberty of
the people must be protected above the
power of government and that it is only
through an adherence to our founding
documents which the people must
understand and know that we will
continue to grow as a free
constitutional republic green button
the motion before us is notwithstanding
the governor's veto on House Bill 319
shall it become law
Constitution requires a roll call
two-thirds vote is required to override
a veto
members take your seats this is a roll
call vote
foreign
become law
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Myler
for a parliamentary inquiry
if I believe that 319 was a flawed bill
from the beginning
and if I believe that this August body
should not
be mandating graduate requirements for
our higher institutions of higher
education our colleges and community
colleges
would I then vote red
to sustain The veto and negate the
proposal for the override thank you Mr
Speaker
Motrin Forest is notwithstanding the
governor's veto show HP 319 become law
state constitution core has a roll call
a two-thirds voters required to override
a veto if you're in favor
of having the bill become law you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
and wish to sustain the governor's veto
you will press the red button boarding
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
thank you
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will attend to stay to the vote
143 voting a 181 voting Aid the
governor's veto and three night House
Bill 319 assistance
also attend to Governor's veto
on House Bill 1022 permitting
pharmacists to dispense the drug Ivy
mechten by means of a standing order in
establishing a commission to study the
use of ivory mechan to treat covet 19.
chair recognizes representative Canuck
also be in order member has a right to
be heard
thank you Mr Speaker
permitting a pharmacist to dispense a
medication by standing order
requires a well-evaluated protocol
established through a broad consensus of
providers and pharmacists using the best
available data
a broad consensus supporting the use of
ivermectin and covid does not exist
this is not to say that Ivermectin is
not a good drug it is excellent for the
treatment of parasitic worms but
efficacy in covid is not proven
you will hear claims that over a hundred
Studies have shown Ivermectin to be
helpful in reducing the severity and
duration of covid-19 but this is simply
not true
there have been numerous studies
regarding Ivermectin and covid-19 which
sound compelling
the member will suspend
the member has a right to be heard if
you need to have a conversation please
take it out in the annual room
memory may continue thank you
you will hear claims that over 100
Studies have shown Ivermectin to be
helpful in reducing the severity and
duration of infection in covid-19 but
that's simply not true the numerous
studies regarding Ivermectin that sound
compelling often have design flaws
serious flaws
a high quality study of medication
efficacy must be randomized
double-blinded and placebo-controlled
and most of the studies in Ivermectin
Paul be so far are limited by small
sample sizes no blinding no
randomization the use of concomitant
medications or poorly defined study
groups
when I last spoke at the well about this
bill
even the well-designed studies had
significant limitations such that
definitive conclusions regarding the
clinical efficacy of ivermectin in the
treatment of covet 19. could not yet be
reached
since then
the Cochrane collaboration and
internationally recognized independent
group with Decades of experience in
analyzing medical literature updated
their review findings of ivermectin and
covet 19.
stating that there is now High certainty
evidence that Ivermectin has no
beneficial effect for outpatients with
covid
no evidence that Ivermectin prevents
covet infection and no certain evidence
that it has any benefit for inpatients
with covid
now the final version
passed by both Chambers allowed
Ivermectin to be distributed
and then have that Authority's sunset
July 1 2024 and it created a commission
to review the data regarding efficacy of
ivermectin and treating covid in order
to make a recommendation as to whether
the authorization for a standing order
should be renewed well that's totally
backwards
it is inappropriate to legislatively
pretend there is a consensus
and then evaluate to see if one actually
exists
if it is determined by quality studies
that Ivermectin has a place in treating
covet at some point in the disease
process it will gladly commonly become
prescribed
so the point is the governor is correct
in vetoing this bill and his veto
message States
quote the state currently has only four
instances in which pharmacists can
dispense medication without a
prescription
those medications are smoking cessation
contraception substance use disorder and
treatment for sexual assault all of
which have gone through rigorous reviews
and vetting to ensure that they meet all
necessary protocols prior to a
medication be dispensed by standard
order standing order
all drugs and medications should be
subjected to that same rigorous process
if they are to be dispensed by standing
order
end quote
Ivermectin fails that process of
rigorous review
and as he pointed out Ivermectin can
still be prescribed off-label by a
provider if that is desired by the
provider and the patient
so in summary
standing orders with pharmacists should
not be used to dispense medications for
indications which are not clearly
supported by the best available medical
evidence
and Ivermectin does not reach that level
of evidence
the governor's veto should not be
overridden we should let high quality
research guide the practice of medicine
we should not legislate the practice of
medicine so please press red to vote no
on the motion to override The veto thank
you Mr Speaker Mr member yield the
questions
in the interest of time no
I
remember does not yield chair recognize
representative Abramson
thank you Mr Speaker I rise in support
of HP
10 22 notwithstanding the governor's
veto
the bill simply provides an option for
licensed Physicians
or advanced practice registered nurse to
provide a standing order for pharmacists
to dispense Ivermectin which many many
Studies have shown has been very
effective in combating other viruses
but the New Hampshire GOP platform
States quote we believe that the liberty
of parents to direct the upbringing of
Health Care education and well-being of
their child
of their children is a fundamental right
decisions in regard to the upbringing
Healthcare education well-being of
children should be the free choice
of parents acting on their children's
behalf unimpeded by intrusive government
regulation and control Mr Speaker
parents not politicians lawyers
activists judges and bureaucrats must
have the right to raise and educate
their own children as they see fit and
make important medical decisions
with their family doctor
our Declaration of Independence
says also we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal that they are endowed by their
creator with certain inalienable rights
that to secure these rights governments
are instituted among men deriving the
just power from the consent of the
governor whereas the Republican platform
States we believe that the New Hampshire
and United States constitutions were
written by the forefathers to limit our
government not to limit our freedom it
must be a decision left between doctors
and parents and patients not left up to
politicians and bureaucrats green button
let's remember yield to questions
remember yields it's in about the salary
you may inquire
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representative for taking my question
you know I'm not a medical person or
anything like that a doctor nothing like
that I'm an old morning that breaks
stuff but anyways I did a Google search
while I'm sitting in the seat and I look
at everyone that's using I remember
medicine it seems like this medication
do you know if this is being used that
the doctor in Congress is issuing it to
Congressional people and rich people are
getting hold of this medicine but the
poor people are being shut down on this
medication
I've I've been told that but I haven't
been given names of politicians and
wealthy people but I I do know that uh
the common people are being deprived of
a lot of the uh leading medication in
fact that was admitted by uh Senator Ted
Kennedy of Massachusetts that because of
his connections he was able to get
access to much better Medical Care than
the rest of us thank you thank you for
the question
the house will be in order
the motion before us is notwithstanding
the governor's veto show HB 1022 will
become law
state constitution requires a roll call
two-thirds vote is required to override
a veto this will be a roll call vote
members take your seats
thank you
most motion before it's not with stating
the governor's reader shall HB 1022
become law
chair recognizes representative canark
for a parliamentary employee
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that standing orders with
pharmacists should not be used to
dispense medications for indications
which are not clearly supported by the
best available medical evidence
and if I know that Ivermectin does not
reach this level of evidence
and if I know that if a person wants to
take Ivermectin or wishes to give it to
their child
they have every right to have that
discussion with their medical provider
who can prescribe it off label as this
bill only prevents a pharmacist from
dispensing Ivermectin by standing order
it does not preclude having a
conversation with your doctor and
getting a prescription if you so desire
and if I know that we should not
legislate the practice of medicine but
rather we should let high quality
research guide the practice of medicine
would I then press red to vote no on the
motion to override The veto of
hb1022 thank you Mr Speaker do I
recognize representative anyone for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that contrary to The veto
message taking Ivermectin does not limit
future treatment options
and if I know that pharmacists are the
professionals that are best trained to
assess an individual's risk and their
medication interactions just as is
commonly done in Europe
and lastly if I know that if if
Ivermectin is helpful it is helpful
early and wasting valuable time waiting
for an appointment with a doctor misses
that window would I then press the green
button to override the governor's veto
the motion before us is notwithstanding
the governor's veto shell HB 1022 become
law
state constitution requires a roll call
a two-thirds vote is required to
override a veto if you're in favor
having the bill become law you will
press the green button if you are
opposed and wish to sustain the
governor's veto you will press the red
button bony stations are open for 30
seconds
foreign
[Music]
president had an opportunity to vote
also attend the state of the vote
144 voting yay 170 voting a the
governors
veto is sustained
house will attend the governor's veto
message on House Bill 1131 relative to
facial covering policies for schools
chair recognizes
senator blazik
foreign
representative Weiler
thank you Mr Speaker
I Rise to overturn The veto of 11 31.
the face mask bill
I had several requests to file this bill
for mothers who were frustrated to get
trying to teach young children to
properly wear masks
they were also asking why the students
were still required to mask up after the
mask requirement for the rest of us was
repealed
we had hours of testimony in both the
house and the senate about the
unreasonableness and the restrictions
not just parents
but coaches
picture a basketball game with the
players running up and down the court
with masks on
bus drivers
testified we heard from a scientist who
pointed out that the children were the
least susceptible to the covet virus and
that no members of this group had had a
serious attack nor had any member died
in this group
speech pathologists testified that it
had set back speech therapy for a year
as children need to see the mouth
movements to properly speak
after all this the governor vetoes the
bill
of all the hypocrisies he says this
should be a local decision
did he not read the bill
local in my mind that I believe in your
minds is that the parents are the right
decision makers not the school board the
school board never claimed any
scientific reason for their rulings or
why children need masks when no one else
was required to wear them
even in a language in his veto message
to quote
the state must remain steadfast in
protecting local control as decisions
like this are best left to authorities
closest to parents and families where
they can work with their neighbors to
decide what is right for their children
yes that's what we're saying in this
bill parents should decide
let's send the message that this sick
legislation believes that when a local
decision is needed that we believe that
local decision is made at the family
level and not by an unelected
superintendent
please push the green button and
overturn this veto vote green vote green
thank you
the motion before us is notwithstanding
the governor's veto shall hb1131 become
law
the state constitution requires a roll
call a two-thirds voters required to
override a veto this will be a roll call
vote members take your seats
materials
clear
the motion before us is notwithstanding
the governor's veto show hb1131 become
law
this is going to be a roll call vote do
you recognizes representative luno for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this is a
flawed Bill wouldn't I just press the
red button to sustain The veto thank you
chair
also be in order
chair recognize representative blazer
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
it should be 11 31 is a parents Rights
bill
and Mr Speaker if I know that there is
no more local of a control than
individual and parental control
and if Mr Speaker if I know that no
politician at any level should be able
to force a child against the will of
their parents to cover their breathing
holes then I would now press the green
button to overturn The veto on HB 1131
also be in order
the motion before is notwithstanding the
governor's veto show HP 1131 become law
state constitution requires a roll call
a two-thirds vote is required to
override a veto if you're in favor of
having the bill become law you'll press
the green button your opposed and wish
to sustain the governor's veto you will
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
everybody
[Music]
was president had an opportunity to vote
household attended state of the vote
150 voting a 170 voting a the governor's
veto was sustained
house will attendant Governor's veto
message on House Bill 1454 relative to
permits for sighting of new landfills
chair recognizes representative
Tucker
so I'm here
to talk about and ask
for
an override of the governor's veto on H
bill
HB 1454.
there are many people in the balcony
there were people here on the Plaza
we've had petitions this is a bill that
has enormous
enthusiasm around the state
it's a bipartisan bill it was from the
outset
there were people in Northern New
Hampshire
who were very concerned about the issue
of landfills
small groups of people gathered then
those groups grew to larger groups
there was an effort between the house
and the Senate there were people who
joined groups we had wired articles at
Town meetings supporting this idea
and we moved across town lines then
across county lines and now it's become
clear that this is a Statewide issue
this last year we have learned a lot
more about contaminants and groundwater
and pfas and bacteria and all these
things we don't really like to think
about that can happen under our feet
when we can't see it we think everything
is fine and it's not fine
now at the last minute we're hearing
rumbles that there are claims that this
bill will affect potential expansions of
existing landfills but that's just not
true there's a key sentence in this bill
which I want to read to you
nothing in this paragraph of this bill
shall be construed to prohibit the
expansion of any landfills that are in
operation at the time this paragraph
takes place this is very important this
makes it so this bill is something that
can be passed now
to deal with an imminent problem
and to protect our very precious Waters
all over the state
as the prime sponsor let me assure you
that it was always my intention as well
of the bipartisan sponsors in the House
and Senate to craft a bill that applied
only to new landfills we believe we've
succeeded and that it is impossible to
read that sentence any other way we have
concurrence on a phone conversation that
was lengthy with director wimsat and I
assure you that there is nothing here
that could be a problem
at the moment
three Republican speakers are ready to
speak to this bill
but no one signed up to oppose
this
override so I leave it up to the three
speakers
representative Walter Stapleton
representative Matt site no oh I can't
do that I'm sorry I'm sorry
representative can't do that okay
uh
well so you're the one who does it
I will announce the speakers
thank you and they can decide what they
want to do about speaking that's really
up to them meanwhile I urge you all
to do the right thing to do it now
to pass this bill that so many people
have worked on collaboratively for so
long thank you
do you recognized representative
Stapleton
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I st I
stand I arise to
support the override of the governor's
veto
to make HB 1454 law
water is life
the bill is reasonable and Common Sense
protection
of our water resources from potential
leakage from landfills
upon any breach or failure of linings
many people will say Linings never fails
some says they're quite opt to fail
we can't take a chance
locating landfills on permeable soils
without sensible buffer distance to
intervene
upon failure is irresponsible
the Bill's five-year travel criteria
enables detection and Remediation
to be well ahead of a contaminant
leakage
and migration to surface waters
then did the arbitrary 200 feet
existing law which just might not be
enough
buffer to preclude polluting or surface
waters
the time and travel protocol is a
science-based answer to uncertainty
has been utilized in other states to
assure sufficient setback relative to
various soil and strata conditions
this technology approach
has been increasing in use since 2003
and our neighbor State May a state of
Maine has used it successfully for 15
years
even with a six-year multiplier
The veto note
mandates that the Department of
Environmental Services
contract with an engineer or hydrolysist
pursuant the SB 396 reference in it
when evaluating a landfill permit
well that's fine but it sorely Lacks two
things
the qualification of the engineer or
hydrologist
and this and the specific
process that should be involved
it is therefore inadequate for the
purpose of really protecting the waters
HP 1454 fulfills that fills that Gap
provide scientific process for
protection
and we should enact it into law
so I ask you to please press
the green button to enable this bill to
enter into law and protect our precious
Water Resources
water is life thank you Mr Speaker
see I recognize representative Simon
thank you Mr Speaker
my colleague did a wonderful job
explaining the content of the bill so I
won't take much of your time this
morning other than to say when the spill
last came to this chamber it passed on a
unanimous Voice vote and uh
it seems like there are some Rumblings
and some changing of opinion uh and and
in fact it might seem strange that I
would be up here arguing for this bill
this override of this veto in the first
place because on my side of the aisle we
we value very highly free markets and
low regulation and allowing businesses
to do what businesses do and we believe
that because we believe that if we let
people do what they do best then All
Ships rise and the standard of living of
all people will rise as we allow people
to do what they do best but of course I
would almost never go against those
principles but all things have
exceptions
and I believe that this bill presents an
exception to that rule
and uh I'd just like to remind my
friends in this chamber that earlier
this year I suspended my convictions of
those rules as well to help the people
of Merrimack
um because their waterways were
compromised and we stepped in and and we
required of business to remediate
problems due to their waterways because
without water you don't have anything
and it doesn't matter how highly we
Elevate the standard of living of people
if they don't have clean water to work
with then they don't have anything
so coming from the North Country we're
not opposed to more landfills you know
when a few of my colleagues have said
well yeah you know you don't mind citing
landfills unless it's in your backyard I
have one in my backyard I've had one in
my backyard for for 20 years I know what
it's like to have a landfill in your
backyard we're not opposed to having
landfills in the North Country have two
operating at the moment
um all we want is for those landfills to
be uh situated reasonably away from our
water sources
our environment is the basis of our
economy up there if we ruin our
waterways people don't come hunt they
don't come fish they don't come do water
sports
if if our fish are compromised if our
animals are compromised it does great
damage to our economy in the North
country and so we're just we're just
asking for common sense legislation we
don't mind setting under the landfill we
just want it adequately separated from
our waterways so that our waterways uh
can can remain safe
um I hope that you will see this the way
that I do
um that you will vote green to overturn
the governor's veto on hpe 1454 uh help
us protect our waterways for the future
thanks so much
do you recognize representative gay
thank you Mr Speaker
this is my last day
this bill is one more step toward
aligning our New Hampshire Des
rsas with good engineering practices for
safe landfills my son-in-law bills them
House Bill 1454 does not apply to
existing landfills it only applies to
landfills yet to be built
and there's no pressing need to build
more of them right now
this bill allows expanding the ones that
we already have
the mount Carberry landfill just
received approval to expand through
2041.
the Nashua Four Hills landfill is
currently seeking a 30-year expansion
through to 2052.
and when we do need more trash capacity
the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services has shown that 86
percent of land in New Hampshire is
hydrogeologically suitable for sighting
a new landfill
currently requiring only 200 feet
between a landfill and a water body
reveals a lack of concern about
hydrology and soil infiltration we've
come a long way from The Superficial
claims that clay liners last forever and
landfill leaching poses no dangers to
our lakes and rivers and Coastal Waters
we cannot risk having more leaks such as
occurred at the Bethlehem landfill in
May last year endangering the man a man
I practiced
amnestic River New Hampshire has already
has its share of Superfund sites
based on hydraulic conductivity tests
this bill requires that any landfill
proposal near a perennial river lake or
Coastal water
will need to be far enough away that it
would take five years for leachate to
reach the water
The Five-Year travel distance can be
reduced as low as two years if the
landfill Construction Company
incorporates adequate additional
engineering to further control the
leaching
we have a chance to protect New
Hampshire lakes in a big way from
multi-million dollar businesses
namely landfill owners and trash haulers
the New England state that keeps
authorizing more landfills is likely to
end up with the biggest landfills filled
with millions of tons of trash from out
of state
Maine already refuses untreated trash to
be brought into their state
as more comes to light about the
chemical pollution and trash more
adjoining States will still want to
deliver their trash to any other state
that will accept it
this bill got its start after
townspeople from multiple communities
had been trying for years to protect
their Lake but they were little guys
trying to hold a line against a huge
company with enormous resources New
Hampshire citizens should never have to
endure such a battle again
prevention is way cheaper than cleaning
up contamination
House Bill 1454 will be a milestone in
the ongoing race to protect our
Priceless New Hampshire Waters
please press the green button to vote
once more to preserve our precious
rivers lakes and Coastal Waters
thank you Mr Speaker
also be in order
the motion before us was notwithstanding
the governor's veto show HB 1454 become
law
state constitution requires a roll call
a two-thirds vote is required to
override a veto this will be a roll call
vote members take their seats
come on
the motion before us is notwithstanding
the governor's veto show HB 1454 become
long
state constitution also be in order
state constitution requires a roll call
a two-thirds vote is required to
override a veto if you're in favor of
having the bill become law you'll press
the green button if you opposed and wish
to sustain the governor's veto you will
press the red button loaning stations
are open for 30 seconds
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
the house the house will be in order
[Applause]
the gallery will contain itself
the vote is 256 a 65 nay The veto was
overridden
[Applause]
I will clean the gallery if you continue
having outburst
recognize how also be in order
recognize the clerk for a message from
the Senate Mr Speaker the Senate incurs
that the house and the passage of the
following title bill and resolution set
up from the house house bill 2023 making
Appropriations to the Department of
energy for a state emergency fuel
assistance program in a supplemental
electric benefit in relative to Electric
low-income program fund
the house will attend to the governor's
veto message on House Bill 1625
repealing prohibition on entering or
remaining on a public way or sidewalk
adjacent to a reproductive Health Care
Facility
chair recognizes representative Abramson
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I rise
in support of House Bill 1625
notwithstanding the governor's veto
repealing the buffer zone restrictions
this bill is supported by New Hampshire
Liberty Alliance which normally takes uh
the tends to lean pro-choice but they
still do support the repeal of this
restriction in law the U.S Supreme Court
has already rejected the exact same
language of this law
in throwing out the Massachusetts law
the high court recognized both a free
speech Zone and the impracticality of
blocking Free Press and competition
within less than 25 feet of a competitor
by a competitor or a pamphleteer it is
argued
by Governors Hassan and sununu in their
veto messages that this law isn't never
has been and never would be enforced
then why leave it on the books
it is not our is it not our job as
lawmakers to remove victimless crimes
duplicate of laws unconstitutional and
vague statutes and laws that are never
to be enforced is that not our primary
Duty Mr Speaker God warns us in the
Bible that man is not capable of making
laws for his fellow man only God can do
this because only God can foresee every
possibility and every violation of the
rights of man only God can understand
every exception that could ever exist
and every exceptional case that ever
will exist
since Pontius Pilate had Christ executed
man has continued to mechanically apply
the law repeating
I asked for order in the in the chamber
be careful
remember we'll continue
since Pontius Pilate had Christ executed
man has continued to mechanically apply
the law repeating the infamous excuse in
other cases that we were just following
orders men women and children have been
enslaved dismembered hanged flayed
boiled and burned alive because laws
were enforced that were supposed to have
been forgotten
if it's not our job to repeal unenforced
or unconstitutional laws then why are we
here do we have any other purpose than
to update the law itself
why have separation of powers a system
of checks and balances
if we will never act to limit the
arbitrary power of the other two
branches of government
our absolute constitutional mandate
Mr Speaker God was right man cannot
predict the exceptional cases nor second
guess the changing Logics of Court
precedence we cannot foresee nor predict
what will happen in a thousand of cases
and this is why we recognize the right
of juries to nullify bad laws in badly
interpreted laws
yet in a greater sense it has been a
dereliction of Duty for this body to
continue to leave this and many other
rsas in place after the courts have
thrown that language out for vagueness
for contradiction for jurisdiction or
jurisprudence for reasons of clarity for
sanity or for constitutionality we took
an oath or affirmation when we offered
to hold this office to uphold and defend
that Constitution and whether we like it
or not
the Next Generation
judges Us by how often we keep our
agreements stand by our word and stand
by those words
sorry
if that Constitution is in anyone's in
the way of anyone's agenda propose a
constitutional amendment as I have but
don't shrug off our duty stand firm and
serve as a role model for the Next
Generation
the New Hampshire GOP platform States
quote encourage individuals and
organizations who provide alternatives
to abortion by meeting the needs of
mothers through adoption support
counseling and Educational Services on
unquote Hard Times create strong men
strong men create good times good times
create weak men and weak men create Hard
Times green button
do you recognize representative Marjorie
Smith
thank you Mr Speaker
and once again the Earth will shake
moderately not the way it did earlier
but I am here to support
the governors
fito
that's why the Earth is shaking
and the since the governor vetoed this
bill
16 States
have have denied women
and their families and their doctors the
right for the women to control their own
bodies
what has happened as a result of that is
that in many other states
the people who have been opposed to
Reproductive Rights are now looking
around for something to do and they're
coming to New Hampshire
so that increasingly those people who
provide Health Care to women and in some
cases to men have found an increase in
the number of people
who have stood in front of their
facilities
I
know there are lots of opinions I tend
to like to stick with just the facts not
suppositions not what other people might
say not what a political party might say
but the facts are
that the language in in the buffer zone
bill that law that exists has
indefinitely not
been overturned by any judicial body
and it is an appropriate language to
help make it possible to protect Public
Safety and I ask you on that basis alone
to support the governors of Ito thank
you very much
gear recognize from senator walper
Mr Speaker I rise in opposition to the
governor's veto
I do so not because as the esteemed
representative from Durham said that our
buffer of Zone law has been found
unconstitutional I do so because it
likely will
and like we will simply because it
violates a higher pretty hard and fast
Supreme Court
precedence about
curtailment of speech based on Viewpoint
discrimination
and since our law
is explicitly Viewpoint discrimination I
don't believe it will be upheld
so that's one reason why I oppose it
the bigger is you know just as well
is because it isn't it intends
to restrict that freedom of expression
that we find so important in our country
that's its intent
and as such I couldn't cotton it either
way
but on the in addition to that
the law is totally unnecessary it was
unnecessary the day it was drafted it
was unnecessary the day it was passed
it's been unnecessary for the whole time
it's been on the books and as near as I
can tell it will continue to be totally
unnecessary there has never been a case
where this buffer zone would have
stopped any infringement of the law
never in the history of the state of New
Hampshire has there ever been a single
case
year after year as we have discussed
this bill from the day it came in until
today has there even been complaints
to the police
it does not happen
because the people that are out there
who are advocating
for the saving of babies lives
do so out of a spirit a spirit of love
not of hate
so Mr Speaker there was unnecessary it's
likely unconstitutional I urge you to
press the green button
the motion before us and notwithstanding
the governor's video show HB 1625 become
law state constitution requires a roll
quality two-thirds vote is required to
override a veto this is going to be a
roll call vote members take your seats
foreign
thank you
the motion before is notwithstanding the
governor's veto show HB 16 to 25 become
law
also be in order
state constitution requires a roll call
a two-thirds vote is required to
override a veto if you're in favor of
having the bill become law you will
press a green button if you are opposed
and wish to sustain the governor's veto
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
had an opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
145 voting a 175 voting a the governor's
veto is sustained
the house will attend to a motion to
suspend House Rules
Mr recognize the clerk Mr Speaker
representative Abramson moves that house
rules be so far suspended as to permit
late drafting introduction and
consideration at the present time
without being drafted by the office of
legislative Services required printing
referral to committee public hearing and
report from Committee of a bill relative
to limitations on prosecution for
first-degree assault and if said bill of
passes to allow immediate third reading
chair recognizes representative Abramson
thank you Mr speaker and I'm asking that
the rules be suspended to reintroduce
oh I'm sorry
asking the In This Very exceptional uh
circumstance that the rules be suspended
for the reintroduction of a bill that
this house has passed unanimously three
times before and the Senate has passed
unanimously that the Senate Judiciary
Committee and the house criminal justice
committee have passed unanimously
this is House Bill 1067 was was just
dealing with the problem that we brought
up
that if a child is the victim of felony
assault many of the attackers have been
getting away I'll remember I remind a
member this is on suspension of the
rules not the bill itself
just reminding members of the content of
the bill if that's all right why you
need to suspend the rules is what this
is about not the bill itself the content
that a bill seeing that it doesn't exist
the reason for the need to suspend the
rules is that hundreds of children are
injured every month that children in New
Hampshire are killed every year
that this has been an ongoing crisis I
don't think there's any question that
the protection of children is something
that we have uh bent the rules in the
past for if we needed to when children
safety uh took precedence when I ran for
office the first time I I told my
constituents I would put children's
safety first
reason that I initially introduced the
bill
was because of a case where someone was
putting out cigarettes on uh
a four-year-old child's arm okay once
again I'll remind the member this is not
about the content of the bill this is
why you need to suspend the rules
uh can I ask for a clarification why why
is it timely or any of that nature not
what's in the content of the bill
Mike
my question is the urgency is driven by
the
speak to speak to the members not to me
well I'm asking for a clarification for
how I'm being written restricted the
reason for doing this is for the
protecting the public safety of children
which is many members will vote to
suspend the rules only for children's
safety or only for an immediate
emergency
I'm asking for additional distance
that's fine but we don't need to get
into about cigarettes and all that kind
of stuff you know getting into children
so just the process the first time the
house passed this uh unanimously it did
go to the Senate and the Senate because
of the coronavirus because of the
lockdown that bill and many others other
members bills were killed
the second time putting the bill through
it went through the Senate unanimously
but it was vetoed by the governor
without a very clear reason I think I
[Music]
the third time the house passed this
bill again unanimously
and
send it over to the Senate and I
was noticed about the hearing only after
the hearing had occurred it was
literally hours after the hearing had
occurred and the Senate killed the bill
for that reason I lost my primary on
Tuesday so I won't have the ability to
reintroduce the bill but even if if a
member were
this issue will continue on more and
more children will be injured
and the deterring effect of the law is
lost unless we vote to suspend the rules
and allow this essentially one sentence
to be reintroduced
uh to the house and go go to the Senate
and hopefully be signed into law in
response to the governor's concerns
I'm asking members to wave
normal traditions and suspend the rules
and press the green button
chair recognize representative Timothy
Smith
thank you Mr Speaker
everything we do in this chamber is
important all of the legislation that
gets filed is important at least to
somebody
all of the bills that we get from the
other chamber are important and we have
a process that we go through
to handle all of these important issues
that we deal with
we typically
at least in the 10 years I've been here
only make exceptions to that in severe
circumstances of imminent emergency
national disasters and things of that
nature there's some huge flood we got to
clean it up there's a huge ice storm in
the whole State's Frozen and the power
lines have fallen down we got to do
something about it we get called back by
the governor
to take action in response to some you
know uh Court decision like what
happened a few years ago with the
Wayfair thing we suspend the rules in
order to circumvent our normal
legislative calendar in order to handle
those immediate time-sensitive issues we
only do that very sparingly when there
is an immediate
time-sensitive issue that cannot be
resolved within the normal legislative
calendar
I'm sure that the supporters of the
underlying legislation here feel that
it's extremely important and I'm sure it
is important because every every Bill we
get pass or fail is important
legislation because the work we do here
matters however it does not rise to the
level of a natural disaster some
imminent National catastrophe a viral
pandemic or something if not that nature
that simply cannot wait for the regular
legislative calendar to take its process
next term I would urge everyone to vote
no one
foreign
has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
[Music]
ah
the motion before us is to suspend the
rules
the chair recognizes representative
Timothy Smith for parliamentary inquiry
Mr Speaker if I know that suspending the
rules to circumvent the normal
legislative calendar in a situation like
this should only be done in response to
an unforeseen
disaster or emergency and that nothing
that the underlying proposed bill is
going to address is unforeseen would I
vote no to reject this motion
Jay recognized representative Amberson
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that that this
reason Public Safety and particularly
children's safety is the very reason
that we were sent here
if I know that this very language has
passed this house three times already
unanimously with no voiced opposition
from anywhere
and if I know that even the head of the
state patrol with whom I almost never
agree stated in in committee hearings
that that about half of the murders
that he's encountered are preceded by
exactly these types of domestic violence
attacks that are that are happening
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
many many of these criminals who commit
class a felony
assault against young children some of
them under 10 years old
[Music]
if I know that they have been getting
away with this in some cases including
the case in Seabrook that I mentioned
the because this the way the statute of
limitations is written would I now press
the green button so that we can put this
one sentence into law
the motion before us is suspension of
the rules
this is a roll call vote for in favor
you'll press the green button of your
opposed you will press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
the last questions
[Music]
while Memphis president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
56 voting a 257 voting a the motion
fails chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne for a
motion to adjourn from the early session
the question is on the motion to adjourn
from the early session
thank you Mr Speaker resolve that the
house now adjourned from the early
session that the business of the late
session be in order at the present time
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
it was a post name do you guys have it
and the motion is adopted
I ask that members stay in their seats
we have some announcements and then we
have some unanimous consent so I'm
asking members to stay in their seats
chair recognizes representative Graham
for an announcement
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this is
an announcement for the members of
Public Works and highways hopefully you
remember and have read your calendar
that we do have an executive session 10
minutes after the final gavel here
in room 201 203 of the lob and we have
to exec one bill if we don't have a Corp
we come back some other day so please
make the effort and the vice chair has
arranged for a photographer to take our
group picture thank you very much Mr
Speaker
chair recognize representative Claudia
for announcement
thank you Mr Speaker could I please see
the Sullivan County delegation
immediately after the session in Section
5 for a brief meeting so that we can
review and vote on some minutes from our
August 23rd meeting as required by the
Department of Revenue Administration
thank you
chair recognizes the clerk for a message
thank you Mr Speaker two quick
announcements one please clean out your
seat pockets and mailboxes in the back
of the chamber second announcement in
the State House Visitors Center there
are holiday cards for our military New
Hampshire challenge there are several
cards where they are going to be sent to
troops stationed overseas at the
holidays please feel free to stop by and
sign your name thank you
communities
this is likely the last time the
legislature will meet before the new
term begins in December December
there are many of you who have chosen
not to run for re-election
have chosen to seek another office
or unfortunately some of you have been
dealt a Fate on Tuesday that you were
defeated in your primary
whatever the case may be
we want to thank you for your service to
your communities in the state of New
Hampshire by serving in this historic
body
with those of you not returning next
term please rise so we can thank you for
your service
[Applause]
[Music]
I I
I just want to add
that it's been a difficult two years for
all of us
I hope and pray that next session
that we have a much easier time than we
have had over the last two years
and before we get on to
your unanimous consent
I'd like to give special recognition to
a few members who are not returning
that have given 20 years or more to
public service in the general court
our dean of the house Laura panelakis 44
years
[Applause]
if we had some more bills Laura I'd ask
you to come up again but
Betsy McKinney she's not here 38 years
[Applause]
David Walsh 36 years
Norm major 26 years
[Applause]
Jackie Kelly Pitts 26 years
Judah Spang 24 years
[Applause]
in John Graham 20 years
foreign
years of service between these seven
members
a true Testament to public service
for what reason does a member rise
thank you Mr Speaker I'd moved to the
remarks of the speaker for the past
couple of minutes be placed in the
permanent Journal
without objection
[Music]
[Applause]
I recognize the clerk for sending a
message Mr Speaker I have two sent
messages from the Senate Mr Speaker the
Senate has voted to sustain the
governor's veto on the following bill
Senate Bill 200 apportioning
congressional districts and Mr Speaker
the Senate has voted to sustain the
governor's veto on the following Bill
H.B 1454 relative to permits for the
sighting of new landfills
Jr recognizes
under unanimous consent Wendy Chase
representative Wendy Chase
thank you Mr
and thank you my colleagues at the house
for giving me this opportunity to speak
this morning my father-in-law Major
Robert Freeman Chase U.S army retired
was put to rest alongside of his beloved
mother father and sister
today is also the last New Hampshire
house session I will be tending as a
Stratford County district 18 state
representative
dad was so proud of my four years at the
legislative service and he loved to
discuss his concerns about driving
pedestrians he was 96.
pedestrian safety and always did I see
the governor today
after each day in Concord I would kneel
by his side and tell him about my day he
loved to watch our Judiciary YouTube
committee hearings always sharing his
thoughts on how I did and how many times
I got up
Bob was born in Lynn Mass on July 17
1926 and at the age of 18 He enlisted in
the Army to fight in World War II
after basic training he served with
company L of the 405 405th Infantry
Regiment
102nd Infantry Division known as the
Ozarks
Bob's baptism of fire came in April of
1945 during their assault Over the Rhine
River
his unit discovered a war crime in Garda
lake in Germany
when he was
when he was being interviewed by Andrew
bigow for the book The rifle which if
anybody has not read that it's
absolutely terrific all War Stories
World War II veterans that are still
with us
dad told him one of the hardest moments
for him was seeing the bodies of almost
a thousand civilians pushed into a barn
and set on fire by the USS troops it was
unbearable each fellow took his turn to
go over and see what they could do to
help and he said I'd seen enough at this
point
at the conclusion of the war Bob spent
several months in arrest camp in Germany
to recover from his injuries after the
war Bob remained in service for his
country serving as an officer in the
101th engineer division as a combat
engineer and then as an officer in the
Air Defense command which was
responsible for protecting the U.S
mainland from air attacks he retired
from the Army in 1969 as a major
but married and raised four children in
Nahant Massachusetts and after the death
of his beloved wife Dorothy in 1969 he
moved the family to Northampton New
Hampshire
he had a very successful business career
with several different companies and in
1980 he founded the New Hampshire clinic
for hypnosis
Bob always enjoyed spending time with
his family and friends he loved word
woodworking restoring antiques auctions
and collecting toys especially Hess
trucks got a lot of them at those
the the number one question each time
Dad saw me and we discussed my day in
Concord was
but do you really like what you're doing
in my reply
it was always yes
and he would Pat my hand
I miss you Dad I miss our conversations
and it was only fitting that I complete
my service to the house my constituents
and to you by honoring your life thank
you very much for this opportunity
[Applause]
[Music]
what reason to memorize I just moved to
put the remarks my friend from
Rollinsford permanent Journal without
objection chair recognizes represent a
bell to sorrow
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker for me it's been a long ride
this is one of the most honorable things
I've ever done in my life next to my
time as a Marine
I thank the clerk Paul Smith for the
great job he's done in support I've had
for many years from you and I hope
you'll be up here for the next 16 20
years for others make it a difference
right
but anyways I won't say too much about
the speaker because I've known the
speaker for a long long time and I mess
with him about riding up here back in
the day with a horse and tied up out
front
but anyways when I first came up here I
got elected in November I came up here
in one of the best chairman I've ever
had and you all know him was Chris
Roberts
Chris Roberts is no longer here he's
been Keen he
I learned a lot from that guy but what a
lot of people didn't know that got mad
at me in the beginning called me names
was Chris Roberts and I served in the
Marines together
we were in the same unit we went to
Desert Storm together there was a
Brotherhood between Chris and I so those
were on that committee back then when
Chris kept coming to me for the answers
on Veterans issues it was because the
Brotherhood that we had serving hand in
hand together in war and in the uh
Garrison
but anyways my time up here working with
Democrats and Republicans I made some
great friends when I got married I had
five or six Democrat Representatives at
my wedding
many years complained for many years
about me and wanted me to resign and I
can tell you a quick Story one time when
somebody wanted me to resign for
something I said I wanted to speak a
Bill O'Brien's office there were people
sitting at the table I took my gun off
my uh side I set it on the table and I
said I'm here to resign he said no
you're not go back to work but anyways
that's another story
when I first came here we worked hand in
hand together Republicans and Democrats
we were friends I still got a lot of
good friends here
over the last few years this has changed
drastically I say good morning I'm a
nice guy I'm a happy guy I'm a how you
doing everything else I say hi to some
there and they just walk by it wasn't
like that years ago years ago we went to
tandy's or which was the Capital Grille
we had a great time over there uh
together my good my friend Mike O'Brien
and I are from Cambridge there a lot
don't know why we get along okay but
he's the Irish side I'm the Italian side
my good friend Peter leishman and Maggie
Smith we went to Turkey together
everyone thought I was going to get them
killed okay oh you're going with Al bald
the sorrow but in anything we had a
great time and if anything I saved them
on what to do and we will be in gas we
were right in the middle of a riot being
guest and who so who was the only van
that none of his had gas in your eyes
tears snots coming out right because
they listened to me all right
this has been one hell of a ride every
build what you don't know that I filed
as a veteran as a veteran activist I had
Democrats on my bill I made them
non-partisan I had quite as a chairman
twice I had a great committee I have to
thank my good uh Rank and member Linda
Massimo who we became very good friends
for a long time okay and we worked hand
in hand everyone in my committee I've
given them opportunity and I told them
just like I did the Democrat Party and
the Republican party did not send us
here your constituents did you vote by
your heart and if you believe in
something you stand by it and I told
them all on both parties that in my
committee that's why we had such a great
time working hand in hand together I
hope and I've been in this business for
many years so you don't know I was a
Democrat for many years okay my
grandfather was a fortune mayor I grew
up sitting at the table with the
Kennedys grew up with chip O'Neill okay
my grandfather was Al valucci 50 years
politics but what I'm trying to say is
back then we all we might disagree but
we worked hand in hand together eighty
percent of the legislation in this house
we all come together
but yet some attack each other
personally or they want to throw stones
at you and call you everything in the
book and that's me I've been called
everything in the book okay I've been
attacked over and over and over and for
no reason because you really didn't know
me because you looked at me and said wow
he's an ass okay but really I'm an old
marine and Marine Corps mentality take
the hill but make sure you teach the
team everyone else so they survive and
that's what we did up here we came
together in many many issues and I'm
hoping the future we come back together
the way it was
okay
[Applause]
I
I gotta admit you know my good friend
over here you know the former speaker
and yes we're friends we're also
Brethren together uh we're also fellow
veterans he did a great job we worked
hand in hand if you noticed many times
when I was the floor leader I got up
because I recognized his voice being
weak he was in the Army so I understand
you know and I and I got up and I
brought him uh Halls to help him out of
his voice am I right all right and the
speaker he had the same thing you know I
mean we've been together a long time to
speak has done a great job he's treated
Republican Democrats he did everything
he can to bring us together but because
of Colvin caused us all problems we were
separated we weren't doing like we used
to do over the years there so we really
didn't get to know each other
okay we have some Representatives here
we're always in attack mode always in
attack mode if a republican looked the
wrong way he was an idiot he was
attacked if a Democrat looked the wrong
way she was attacked or he was attacked
there was people sitting in his house
twittering on every word we said Twitter
and oh and it's a shame that's how to
stop
that's gonna stop we got to work hand in
hand we all have families we're all
volunteers
my family my kids used to say Dad why do
you do this they attack you all the time
why and I told them I do it for love a
country love a state love of elderly
people that I've worked hand in hand
with my good friend Catherine Rogers God
bless her and I worked hand in hand on
an elderly protection Bill my good Remy
uh Remy cushion we worked hand in hand
on another bill this is the way it
should be
you know but for many years I was called
names and this and that and it but you
really didn't know it was your stupidity
your ignorance that did that that's all
it was but I'm asking you to please once
and for all bring this house back
together the way it was and that way
there we will prosper and I'm going to
be watching from afar
okay as I work on my tan there and as
you know and I'm hoping my good friend
John Burt don't make any remarks because
what you all don't know you attack John
Burt but I have five percent African
blood in me did you know that okay so
when you called me a racist over the
years
my family is African-American okay but
I'm a racist you see what I'm saying so
think before you attack somebody okay
because you're wrong
okay we're all a family trying to do the
right thing we're just coming from
different directions thank you
[Applause]
for what reason does a member rise Mr
speaker I would like to move that the
remarks of the previous speaker
be put in the permanent Journal
without objection
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
the committee on enrolled bills has
examined and found correctly enrolled
the following entitled House Bill House
Bill 2023 making Appropriations to the
Department of energy for a state
emergency fuel assistance program and a
supplemental electric benefit and
relatively electric low-income program
fund signed by the committee members
Kevin Evart and Jason Osborne
Joe recognizes representative Kelly
Pitts
thank you for those who endured
I
I don't say much all the time and if I
do I'll cry
all I can say is thank you
to everyone who has been kind
and brought me along over 26 years I was
going to stay one term
um to the clerks to the maintenance
people to the security people to
everybody else behind us to the
committee assistants who really had the
knowledge and you could run to and say
help me and to my family
to Bert I'm gonna miss the hot dogs
um
thank you
thank you so much we are a family we are
sometimes dysfunctional and like a
family we argue
I can't remember when I first came in
here I'm Brash because I was a marine
wife
not ALS
[Laughter]
and I had and I came from New York City
and if you're quiet in New York City
you'll get lost under a Subway
so
thank you again that's all I want to say
and it has been a great ride over 26
years thank you all
[Applause]
what reason is memorize
without objection
chair recognize representative Schultz
thank you Mr Speaker
after hearing all the folks that have
served for so long I hope you will also
see
um I speak of a patriot who has been
with us for four years but we have an
opportunity to help the work she will be
doing
um
because my colleague from the other side
of Loudon Road
uh made history
she's also one of the most patriotic
people I know
and I wanted to share this good news
about the work she'll be doing
when she was elected after a heated and
sometimes ugly campaign her Victory made
it into the New York Times and all kinds
of media and overseas it made
international news
and all the way across the globe to her
native country of Afghanistan
where she and her family had to flee
because her father a patriot to the
United States served and assisted our
military
um he was an interpreter they became
targeted by the enemies and after stays
in multiple refugee camps her family
made it to Concord she graduated from
Concord High School
got married graduated from nhti
a mother of three and I don't even think
you're 30 yet
[Laughter]
um
I'm editing a few things here sorry
she still would like to be with us but
what she's doing instead out of the out
of just makes sense that she'd be the
person to do this and what inspired me
were the speeches that a few folks and
especially my colleague from Londonderry
as the daughter of a marine Semper
Fidelis
ly about Afghanistan and how our
withdrawal from Afghanistan
was
parched and what is difficult is that
there wasn't a plan necessarily to help
those families and those Patriots who
helped our country
but now more and more of them are being
um
are are leaving Afghanistan and my
colleague our colleague Sophia was here
will be working or is working for a
centria resettling new Americans
here in New Hampshire mainly right now
in Concord and Manchester and I said I
would like to recognize this what do you
need because just like our ancestors
mine from Germany and Scotland Etc you
know didn't have a lot when they got
here fleeing a country
she said well the number one thing they
need is housing well obviously the
housing is a big issue here so if anyone
has any connection to fair housing or
assisting connections with landlords
that sort of thing obviously as
accessory dwelling units or any thoughts
if you're a member of a church or a
temple or other congregation that would
like to help that's their number one
need I mean
um
some have been here for six or more
months and they have no home yet
they also need volunteers people to help
teach English and for another
colleague from Loudon uh
they need people to help teach the
citizenship test as they are on the path
to citizenship
I test most of us couldn't pass by the
way
um and they also need donations so I
just wanted you to know that we talk
about people who serve our country we
obviously as legislators serve our state
many of you served our country many of
you related to people who served our
country but don't forget that our new
Americans include people like Sophia and
her family who fled countries where
where because they assisted our country
they now are new Americans and I hope
that if you have the opportunity to be
helpful that you will find a way to be
helpful and that's not as much as a
recognition but a thank you for the work
that you're going to be doing and we
will help in any way we can
thank you Mr Speaker
[Applause]
[Music]
I recognize the representative speedia
I'm from Mark's prepared for this
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues you know thank you all for
allowing me the time to speak this
afternoon I know we're all trying to get
out of here so I'll try to be quick
um and I like some of y'all I'm not
seeking re-election this year
um so first I want to thank you for
supporting me throughout my time in the
legislature
um in our work here at the State House
is not easy often and you know but it's
so important and with colleagues on both
sides of the aisle I learned how to be a
better public servant and member of our
community and thank you for those who
taught me the history of the legislature
those who took time to discuss policy
and those who guided me the guided me
through the process of filing a bill to
a signage honestly thank you all but
today not only marks my last day
standing here before you as a member of
this honorable body but it also marks
the beginning of Hispanic Heritage Month
which ends on October 15th and I'm sure
that some of you are like why is it
starting in the middle of a month
um and it's because
um usually or it's you know when it was
created in 1968 by President Lyndon B
Johnson it coincided with eight Latin
American countries Independence Day
including my uh my parents homeland of
Mexico being tomorrow so
um but for many of our Global neighbors
this is a time of Celebration and for
all of us this is a time to learn and
celebrate the rich history of Latin
American countries and those Latinos who
live here in the granite state we can
celebrate Hispanic Heritage Month by
supporting our local Hispanic and Latino
businesses trying out new places to eat
and Shop while you know supporting these
small businesses you can attend events
in person or online you can visit
hispanicheritage month.gov for resources
and events and this month reminds me of
the importance of representation people
who look like me in leadership at all
levels of government you know earlier
this year I met a group of fourth
graders third they were touring the
state house they were out here
and from my district and many of those
students speak Spanish at home they're
bilingual about 50 percent of the kids
who attend the local elementary school
or are like you know are from Hispanic
backgrounds and the look of surprise
when I greeted them in Spanish they were
like yo that's a wild
um they were they were like oh like my
mom is also like either like Mexican uh
Colombian Ecuadorian like like which I
will say you know we're a Hispanic
Community here in New Hampshire is just
incredibly diverse from all parts of
Latin America
so and then you know once we get those
thank you letters from the fourth
graders so many of them were like
showering me they were like yo like
that's so cool that you were that you're
also like me so
um you know for us it uplifts them it
tells them that they too can do this one
day so although we celebrate I you know
we said we can celebrate year round this
month I encourage all of you to pause
and reflect on what this means in the
granite state
um and so thank you for allowing me the
time to speak and thank you for this
fantastic experience here in the New
Hampshire state house and hopefully
maybe one day I'll come back but um I
just appreciate all of y'all thank you
foreign
reason does a member rise
Mr Speaker I raised up to
um
speak about representative just said
from September 15 to October 15 we
celebrate recognized on the sheet for
unanimous consent
yourself
you weren't on the list representative
without objection you can move forward
but
thank you I will I will sign it so I
would like to say that um I wanted to
continue the uh the conversation is uh
representative speeches started from
September 15 to October 15 we celebrate
everything that our culture brings to
this day
everything that we represent we bring
music
we bring food
and we bring joy
I'm honored to be the first Salvadorian
State represented here
representing that um
Hillsborough County 43 Milford
now I'm going to be very quickly and I'm
going to say in Spanish
entitles
soy La Primera representative
salvadorena
against the style
nor
is
thank you so much for giving me the
opportunity to celebrate my closure
today is Independence Day in my country
El Salvador and tomorrow is a state
representative
cultured in Mexico Independence Day so
thank you so much for giving me the
honor to be a representative for these
two sponsors two years as being my honor
[Music]
we're down to the last person that
requested unanimous for consent
representative Burt
thank you
Mr Speaker
[Applause]
[Music]
Mr Speaker
there's a couple reps that are no longer
with us
that I just want to say their names
representative Shaw and representative
valencourt
they taught me a lot up here
representative allencourt said
be friends with everybody
because who you're beating up today
you're going to be best friends tomorrow
on a different bill
and I agree with that
right there is example
you know we've had differences but then
there's been bills that we've joined and
that's the way it should be
the other people that have really helped
me
is representative naughter
baldus Arrow
representative Kelly Pitts and
representative Eaton
they all showed me that we can get along
and that we must get along
in order to
you know make good legislation happen
for the people
I want to thank representative I mean
not representative I apologize clerk
Paul Smith for everything he does for us
his staff and the clerk they work
extremely hard
especially the late nights we're here
and you never see him complain
Mr Speaker
I am very honored
to be here
I promised the voters that I would be
here for every vote
I've been here 12 years and I've never
missed a vote yet
[Applause]
and Mr Speaker there was times I was
nervous about you not hearing me holler
roll call
but you always I always heard you John
but you always did
Mr Speaker I want to thank the voters of
Goffstown where and Darren who allowed
me to sit in their seat
it's not my seat it's their seat
they allowed me to be here for 12 years
I want to thank him for that
I really do thank them for that
and Mr Speaker my wife said I couldn't
get up here and speak
because you know you know she says I'm
emotional most of the time
but I do want to thank my wife
my wife Phyllis Burt
I am so blessed to have her for a wife
I know there's a God
because she is a gift from him
to me
[Applause]
[Music]
and Mr Speaker if if it wasn't for my
wife
we want to raised forty three thousand
dollars for hot dog day
to 10 different dog groups it's pretty
incredible how we can all come together
and go outside for a hot dog
so Mr Speaker
I am not returning and it's sad that I
you know for me you know it's a lot of
emotions it's hard for me to say goodbye
but Mr Speaker I want to thank all of my
friends here
and I want to say God bless you
and I will miss it being here
thank you
Mr Speaker
[Applause]
[Music]
for what reason is a member rise oh he's
my brother
so like I've moved that his remarks me
without objection
representative Osborne moves at the
house standing recess the purpose of
receiving any messages and roll Bill
amendments and enrolled Bill reports
after which businesses concluded the
house shall stand adjourned from the
2022 session
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those May
your eyes have it the motion is adopted